you can put your elbows on the table
and that fell so i'm reading his body
language
which is saying that sucked and so we go
right back to
it i'm joe navarro author former fbi
agent
and this is body language support
[Music]
at erica destiny asks
why does eye contact intimidate the
out of me
well the fact is that it's not just you
a lot of us are intimidated by eye
contact
and in fact all primates avoid
making too much eye contact with each
other apes
will look at the alpha he has the
ability to look over
everybody but everybody else tries to
avoid
making too much of a direct eye contact
and
we humans are much the same
when the eye contact is too direct too
intense
it is intimidating and this is something
that obviously poker players have used
for decades to intimidate each other it
really creates
a subconscious instability
that often drives them to change their
behavior because
they're not aware that they're being
intimidated
at a subconscious level here's a
question from
at like sliced pear can i contact and
long silent gases be
love language cause
when it comes to courtship when it comes
to dating most of the
decisions that we make is non-verbally
and eye gaze behavior is very powerful
when we are in the presence of someone
we enjoy it can certainly be indicative
of
i like this person very much
and i would certainly pay close
attention to it
so on to the next question it comes to
us
from a friend of mine at eric gallard
hey joe what do you think about people
who take off their glasses in the middle
of a meeting
interview or on important points that's
a great question and it often manifests
in different ways
sometimes people take the glasses off
and they rub
the bridge of the nose or they may
massage the back of the ear where the
the glasses rest
and that is to accommodate themselves
they may also take their glasses off to
uh pacify you'll often see people put
them in their mouths as
as they're thinking this is no different
than a pacifier
other people use it almost like a baton
to demark a point as they're talking
while others are using it basically to
create novelty to get other people's
attention
at ezra hamod asks how do i improve my
poker face
the easiest way to improve your poker
face is something that i taught
phil hellmuth a long time ago just keep
in mind you can improve your poker face
but now your poker body
so sometimes we'll reveal things
somewhere in our body but
put your elbows on the table bring your
thumbs together
and you perch your chin
on the thumbs and then you interlace the
fingers
and they block your mouth you look
straight ahead but slightly down
and what happens is you virtually
disappear
because there's nothing there for anyone
to see so after a while
people will avoid looking at you because
there's nothing new there there's no
novelty
at sci suburb asks
my question is when you see the eye
twitch of irritation
how do you use body language to help the
other person feel more comfortable
without directly addressing the fact
that you saw them appear
irritated a lot of times we display
discomfort through our eyes we'll squint
we may look away we may cover the eyes
when something is is bothering us and
the easiest way to make other people
more comfortable
without saying anything is to move
slightly away
and angle yourself humans tend to
approach each other
directly what we don't realize is that
this
actually minimizes face time the closer
we get
the more intense the look this can
act as an irritant one of the best
things that we can do
anytime is when we approach each other
and we we sense that there's some sort
of irritation or psychological
discomfort
is always to move back
and then always angle yourself so that
you're looking at each other at
angles rather than directly
this whether you're in business or
in interpersonal relationships this
actually
minimizes face time where
by angling this increases
face time because it contributes to
psychological comfort
at jessica basic to ask is duping
delight then pretending to experience
the light
or is it like narcissistic smirk
so in 1986 paul ekman
coined the term duping the light and
basically what that looks like
is you have this little smirk on your
face like you're getting away with
something
i would say it's like showing off
you can take great pleasure in getting
away with something
but when you exercise duping the light
it's
uh it's sort of like telling the world
yeah i got away with it
so here we have a question from at
artemis moongod
and he asks are there body language
differences
among different cultures do people of
different countries
display different body language cues yes
in other cultures they say hello
differently
we tend to wave our hands high
and above in other cultures they may do
it more subtly
we tend to say oh everything's okay
and yet in other cultures that's
considered a phallic symbol so they
don't do the
okay sign we like to shake hands
and we do so all over the united states
but interestingly enough
we have cultures within culture so in
new york
you may have more of a strong grip
where in the midwest it might be just a
quick touch of the hands and and
movement away
it's always good to consider the culture
that you're in
because when we mirror these behaviors
it lets others know that we respect them
and that we
are in synchrony with them and of course
as i've always said
synchrony is harmony here's a great
question from
add to believes yes can body language be
submitted as admissible
evidence in court absolutely in the
famous 1967
case of terry versus ohio the supreme
court
considered this and they said if a
police officer
can articulate with particularity
the body language that he or she
observed
it can absolutely be used in court
to justify the actions of a police
officer
to answer your question again absolutely
yes at john robinson asks a
very important question and it's
directed at me
most of your fbi profiling career joe
was before today's more widespread
autism awareness but did you in
interview known autistics were they
different
my approach was always to deal with
the person that was in front of me
however they manifest
there were some people who were on the
autism spectrum
and as an interviewer it's not my job to
figure
their behaviors out other than to note
them
and say how do i get around this you
deal with each human
as they present and you try to work with
them
to establish communications and if that
means stepping back
if that means handing them a piece of
paper if that means not making eye
contact
then so be it dale roxu asks
how can i end a conversation politely
with someone that talks forever
without just walking off tried looking
at the watch with no luck
dale i've been there you try to give off
signals you look at your
watch two or three times but let's face
it with some
nothing may ever work um the first one i
like to do is i
orient my foot towards an exit a lot of
people catch that
and sense that uh i'm moving away
slightly
there's other times when no amount of
body language
gets through to these people and so what
i do is i put my hand on their arm and i
say buddy
i'd love to stay but i gotta run take
care must go
so long oh this is one of my favorite at
sinister vaults ask hey joe
what does it mean when people shake
their leg while sitting
well i'm glad you asked that because i
do that all the time
shaking the leg or the hands or the feet
is a repetitive behavior and just like
twirling the hair
strumming the fingers anything that's
repetitive
is a soothing behavior i do it all the
time and it's just to calm me down
so here we have a great question from at
osana
f i have a question it may be more
difficult to answer
but if anyone can do it it's joe my
question
is why do some people tend to divert
their eyes
to the mouth of the person they're
speaking to
very simple lip reading
a lot of us take comfort in reading each
other's lips as we're talking to each
other and
that's one of the things we found out
when we started masking up for
covid19 is how much we do this
and didn't realize we were doing it at
jolly cx
asks a very important question with the
rise of
aapi hate many asian americans are being
attacked both
verbally and physically what can we do
to pinpoint
specific body language actions in which
one appears hostile
and to avoid conflict there is no
specific
body language that might indicate
hostility
other than things that are quite quite
visible but we know from studies done in
the 60s that there are things that we
can do
by the way we carry ourselves making
ourselves
both physically visible but making
larger something so simple as walking
with a greater stride
looking around making eye contact with
everybody you see
the other one is get off the phone look
around
don't bury your head down and just be
aware of everybody around you and
hopefully
that will help so here's an interesting
question from shut up
talk now what body language do i have to
use to tell the people the next table
that i find them
really interesting and would love to be
friends with them why
are you waiting for body language
sometimes the easiest thing to do is to
say
i find what you're talking about
fascinating do you mind if i join you
and that's often good enough from at
khloe kardashian
i've always been intrigued watching
interrogation videos and looking for
clues in their body language
so have i there's so much information
that we give away
while we're being interviewed our
reactions for instance
to the question that's being asked i
think you're on to something chloe
the fact is that we use body language
to evaluate how people do in
interviews not to detect deception
but to look for their reactions that
might indicate
psychological discomfort so
at andrea and then there's a b
9 7 9 5 one four four
zero how many others could there be with
that number anyway
i'd love the verdict of the professional
body language expert on megan
she twitched she took her head the wrong
way
did not make eye contact a good
performance from a trained
actress so i believe this question has
to do
with the interview with oprah and
meghan markle anytime we see an
interview you really don't know
what's behind the camera and that
affects
everything in front of the camera you
don't know how many people are
there providing lighting sound
how many producers are present who's
moving around
and so forth the second thing that you
don't understand
is the context of everything that has
happened
before the camera is turned on so what i
tell people is this look
when you listen to an interview listen
to the words that are
said and then just compare it to with
what we know
the fact of the matter is we don't know
what was going on because we only saw
what was
in front of the camera not behind the
camera
at inefficient ass is mirroring
someone's body language
equivalent to flirting not necessarily
you can certainly do it to flirt but
it's
not always indicative of flirting
at superstar comms asks
is mirroring body language in
confrontational situations
always beneficial or ill-advised you
know
i think the better question is how do we
use body language to
either improve a situation
or to diffuse it because certainly we
don't want to escalate it if someone's
angry and posturing and yelling and
screaming and puffing their chest out
and you do the same thing
that's counter-intuitive that's just
going to get you
to be angry and agitated and so forth my
philosophy is
one of you has to calm things down and
the easiest way to do that
is not mirror the behaviors to
step back angle your body tilt your head
lower your voice avoid the eye contact
and
take greater control of yourself so that
the person that's
out of control will look ridiculous
while
you look like you have mastery over
yourself
replying to at gigipoo
she asked a great question give me an
example of a power pose
most of us are familiar with the arms of
kimbo elbows out
everybody knows that but we can actually
do a power pose
by placing our elbows on the table
and rather than placing them near us
place them
further apart and then steepling
steepling is
the only behaviors that we humans share
that is indicative of confidence at
the aidan hunt asks you ever see two
people sitting together at starbucks and
wonder if it's a
first date or a job interview yes i have
in fact
so job interviews and courtship behavior
dating have a lot of similarities both
are
drinking coffee at the same time and so
forth so what i look at is
are there differences are they truly
mirroring each other
in a social way or are they mirroring
each other
in a more intimate way but also keep an
eye on the feet because when people like
each other
their feet will go near each other at
jarzeem ask a very timely question i'm
required to wear a face mask to do my
job interview tomorrow but i can't
decide if it's good for me or it's bad
for me
we often think that the whole face is
communicating but the fact is your whole
body's communicating use your eyes to
express sentiments so we use the
eyebrows
as exclamation points tilt your head
when when it's appropriate
use your shoulders to communicate your
whole body communicates
put it to good use at nussan's and gigi
asks if body language is important why
aren't we taught it at school
that's a good question it should be
taught in school we are born
without the ability to speak and so we
must be able to
read the baby in other to take care of
that baby and feed it
number two we assess for danger
non-verbally
and number three courtship behavior we
use
body language so to your question why
isn't it taught in schools
i would argue the better schools do so
here's a question
from i don't make these up folks
at 1 h 3 ll
0 k as in kilo one
t t as in tango tango y
you can tell a lot about a person from
their eyes and body pasture you can see
if they are confident or not and by the
eyes i can always tell
when it doesn't match the smile on their
face well congratulations
this is one of the things that i always
look for is do
all the clues that come from the body
say the same thing sometimes you get
mixed
answers for instance a person will say
yeah i really like that
but as they're saying that for instance
the lip will pull up
so it'll look like this yeah i really
like that
no they don't to look for the synchrony
in all the body language that you read
so congratulation
at 1 h3 ll0
k is in kilo one tango tango
yankee it's no surprise to me that that
people
are both interested and captivated by
body language
it's the primary means by which we
communicate
we may not know all the terms of art but
boy we're interested in the eyes and the
mouth
and the chin and everything else about
us and this is why we study
and we examine body language because
innately we know
this is really the number one way that
we humans communicate with each other
every day